The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: And today I'll
continue with both ideal and
non-ideal, or real,
liquid mixtures.
And let me just say the reason
we're in some sense lavishing
so much attention on this topic
is because, after all,
there's just an enormous amount
of chemistry that
happens in liquid mixtures.
Awful lot of biology.
Awful lot of just processing
of stuff.
Distillation and everything
else.
So there's so much chemistry
that takes place in liquid
mixtures that it is really
important to have a sense of
what the free energy and
chemical potential of each of
the species is doing in there.
Because of course this is what
directly guides the chemistry
that happens.
So I just want to start by
finishing up something, a
couple of things, from the
topics from the last lecture.
One of them is, I derived an
expression for the lever rule.
And I just wanted to
make a little more
explicit the result.
It may not have been
completely clear.
So, I just want to
go back to that.
We had looked at what happens
if you start at some
particular point, labeled one,
and work your way up.
So we're raising the pressure.
So we're in the all gas
region to start.
All gas region of the
phase diagram.
This is xB and yB.
The liquid and gas mole
fractions of B. And the idea
is that here is our
initial value.
Now we're only in
the gas phase.
There is no liquid.
So this is yB of one.
There is no xB at this point.
We raise the pressure.
And at some point, depending on
where we end, we then look
to both coexistence curves to
determine the compositions of
both the liquid and
the gas phases.
So when we look out here,
at the liquid phase.
That gives us xB.
At where I labeled point two, so
there's two after we raise
the pressure.
We started at one.
And then over here, we look at
the gas phase coexistence
curve. so there's our yB
value at two, right?
And I derived an expression for
the ratio of the number of
moles in the gas and
liquid phases.
Because the idea here is, let's
say you're working your
way up on the curve.
If you just barely get to the
coexistence curve, of course
then you could see how
much material you've
got in the two phases.
But there's very little
material still.
You've still got almost
everything in the gas phase
when you first reach here.
And as you work your way up in
pressure, you'd have more and
more liquid.
Of course, if you were to just
keep going, you'd get into the
pure liquid phase.
Typically, though, you might
stop somewhere in the middle
and have some reasonable amount
of material in both
phases, and you want
to find out the
composition in each phase.
And also, want to know
how much material
there is in each phase.
So the result that I derived
was n gas at two
over n liquid at two.
The ratio of total moles in
the gas to the liquid.
What I derived was xA of
two minus yA of one.
Over yA of one.
Minus yA of two, and I just want
to, in some sense, finish
up by making the obvious
substitution, which is, of
course these are
mole fractions.
So I can just write xA
is one minus xB.
And yA is one minus yB.
And I just want to put this in
the terms that are written
here in the phase diagram.
When I got to this result I
pointed out that therefore you
can use the lever rule.
And I just want to make that
a little bit more explicit.
So using that relation, then we
can see that ng of two over
nl of two, total number of moles
in the gas to the liquid
is, now I'm going to substitute
in to get yB of one
minus xB of two over yB of
two minus yB of one.
So all I've done here is
substitute in these
expressions.
And now I'm going to just
switch both of these.
And so I'm going to multiply
both sides by negative one.
So I can write xB of two minus
yB of one over yB of
one minus yB of two.
So that's the result
that I want.
Because if I look at the two
segments of this line, on
either side of the pressure
value I've reached, then what
I see, of course, is that
over here I've got xB of
two minus yB of one.
That's this.
And this part is yB of
one minus yB of two.
That is, it's this part.
And that's here.
And so that's the point, is that
the ratio of moles in the
gas and liquid phases is just
given by the two segments of
this on either side.
And so what this allows us to
see very simply is alright,
I'm going to raise the pressure
at some point.
And depending on how much
material I feel like I need to
collect in the new phase, I
can always determine that
simply by reading off the phase
diagram what the ratio
of these two segment
lengths is.
Now what I want to do.
What what we've done mostly is
just go through these phase
diagrams, see how
to read them.
How to follow events on them
as you change pressure in a
diagram like this.
Or change temperature
in diagrams like I
also showed last time.
Now what I'd like to do is go a
little bit further and just
look at expressions for the
chemical potential and the
free energies.
So that we can, a little more
quantitatively, see
what's going on.
So let's just see what's
happening.
So let's look at the chemical
potentials.
In ideal liquid mixtures.
So everything is derived from
the fact that when we have any
of the constituents in both
phases, the chemical potential
must be equal in both phases.
Right?
So, we can write for A, mu
A of the liquid at some
temperature and pressure must
equal chemical potential of A
for the gas.
That's the partial pressure.
So if we have an ideal gas, and
certainly if we're going
to assume an ideal liquid
mixture, we can safely assume
that it's an ideal
gas above it.
Then we can write
mu A in the gas.
Is just mu A naught.
That's a function of the
temperature plus RT
log of pA over p0.
Nothing new here, this is just
our expression for the
chemical potential in the
gas, with reference
to a standard potential.
Usually one bar.
At whatever the temperature
is.
And, of course, this is how it
varies as the partial pressure
of A in the gas phase varies.
So then we can just write our
expression for the liquid.
At our temperature and pressure,
it's given by mu
naught in the gas phase.
Plus RT log pA over p0.
So it's the same thing.
Because I'm just taking
advantage of this equality.
But of course, this is
an obvious step,
having written this.
But is a super important step.
That's what allows us to do
this treatment in such a
straightforward way.
We know a lot about the
chemical potential of
something in the gas phase.
Since the gas and liquid are in
equilibrium, therefore we
know the chemical potential
in the liquid phase too.
So we can rewrite this by
recognizing that if we just go
to the limit where we only have
pure liquid A, so pure
liquid A. Well, in that case, mu
A naught or sorry, mu A in
the liquid phase, mu A star is
mu A naught in the gas phase.
Plus RT log pA over p0.
And so for the mixture, now all
I'm going to do is just
add and subtract terms.
So we can write mu A in the
liquid at T and p, right?
So this is in the case of the
limit of the pure liquid.
Now we're going to
the mixture.
So it's just mu A naught plus
RT log pA star over p0 minus
RT log of pA star over p0.
Wait a minute, lost a term.
Plus RT log pA over p0.
And all I want to do now
is combine terms.
To write mu A star liquid
temperature and pressure.
Plus RT log of pA
over pA star.
So this is a very convenient
form for it.
And then, of course, we have an
expression for pA, right?
From Raoult's law. pA
is just the mole
fraction xA times pA star.
That's just true for
the ideal mixture.
So now, finally, we can write
that mu A in the liquid at T
and p is just given
by mu A star.
So that's for the pure
liquid at that
temperature and pressure.
Plus RT log of the mole fraction
of A. So that's a
very simple expression for the
chemical potential of A. And
of course the analogous
expression will hold for any
of the constituents.
In an ideal liquid mixture.
By the way, it's convenient
because it looks just like the
chemical potential in a mixture
of ideal gases.
Except that we have liquid
instead of gases, right?
Now, of course, since this is
a mole fraction, it's always
between zero and one.
That means this is always
a negative number.
So what that means is that the
chemical potential in the
solution is always lower than
the chemical potential of the
pure liquid.
Very important result.
So it has all sorts of
implications that we'll see.
One of them is osmotic
pressure.
It means that if I have a
biological cell, or some
container with a membrane
through which one of the
constituents might pass.
So in other words, the let's
say, component A, maybe it's
just water.
It can pass freely, let's say,
from the outside to the inside
of the cell, or from one side
to another of a membrane.
And on one side I've just
got pure water.
And on the other I've got saline
solution or whatever is
in the cells, right?
What's the water going to
do in that situation?
What's going to happen?
Anybody know?
So I've got, I just take fresh
cells and plunk them into pure
water solution.
What happens?
Yeah.
They burst.
Water rushes in.
Because the chemical potential
is lower inside.
It's always lower in solution
than outside.
So water rushes in, and
the membrane expands.
Now, if the membrane is
strong enough, at some
point it may not burst.
And the pressure might
start to go up.
Let's say the membrane
is strong enough to
resist and not burst.
Eventually, the water won't keep
going in indefinitely.
That's because it won't be at
the same temperature and
pressure any more.
In particular, the pressure
will have changed.
So you can build up some high
pressure, what's called
osmotic pressure.
Because of the fact that at the
same pressure the chemical
potential of the water's lower
inside the cell or inside the
enclosure with the membrane.
So water will keep filling.
And at some point the chemical
potentials will equalize
because of the change
in pressure.
And at that point there'll be
an equilibrium established.
We'll see that quantitatively
a little bit later.
OK.
The other thing to notice is,
this is familiar from the
expression for a gas mixture.
What drives the gas mixture?
Remember back when we discussed
mixing of gases and
the fact that they
would mix at all.
What makes that happen?
What's driving it?
Yeah, it's entropy, right?
And that's what's happening
here too.
Of course, in the case of the
ideal liquid mixture, there's
no energetic interaction.
The molecules are
non-interacting in this case.
But of course, entropy is going
to want them to mix.
And that's what's
resulting in the
decrease in chemical potential.
Let's see that a little more
explicitly by just calculating
out the free energy
change of mixing.
So, delta G of mixing.
So we're going to start with
two separated liquids.
And then we'll remove
the barrier.
And we'll have the two
mixed together.
So of course, the free energy in
either case is just the sum
of the number of moles of
each times the chemical
potential of each.
We have expressions for that.
So starting G1 in this case.
It's n of A, number of
moles of A. Times
the chemical potential.
So it's xA mu A star
in the liquid.
Plus nB xB B mu B star
of the liquid.
Here, G of two.
After we let them mix.
Then it's n -- wait a minute.
It's just n.
I think I've got that wrong
in the notes also.
Right, it's just a number of
moles times the chemical
potential in each case.
So it's the number of
moles times xA.
Times mu A in the mixture.
Plus n xB mu B in the mixture.
But we've just figured it out
our expressions for mu A and
mu B, our chemical potentials
of each constituent in the
ideal liquid mixture.
So this is just n xA.
And here's our expression.
And of course these are
going to cancel.
Let's write it out.
So it's mu A star
plus RT log xA.
And then, mu B star
plus RT log xB.
So our delta G of mixing
is just the difference
between these two.
So it's n RT xA log
xA plus xB log xB.
Where have you seen
that before?
Yeah.
The same thing that you had for
the delta G of mixing for
an ideal gas mixture.
Why?
Because we're not accounting for
any interactions between
the molecules in either
of the phases.
And if the molecules aren't
interacting, it's all entropy.
And the entropy term has the
same form in either case.
In microscopic terms, it's just
measuring the fact that
there's more disorder
in the mixture
than in the pure liquids.
Just the same it was
in the gas phase.
OK.
We can see this even more
explicitly if we just recall
that G is V dp minus S dT.
So we can just explicitly
calculate
the entropy of mixing.
Delta S of mixing is just the
partial of delta G of mixing.
Negative partial.
With respect to temperature.
At constant pressure.
So it's just minus n R xA
log xA plus xB log xB.
So that's our entropy
of mixing.
We can calculate our
enthalpy of mixing.
Just delta G of mixing.
Plus T delta S of mixing.
But it's immediately apparent
that these are just going to
cancel when we multiply
this by T. So there's
no enthalpy of mixing.
Just as we expect when
there are no
energetic terms involved.
It's all entropy that's
driving the mixture.
One more detail, it's
straightforward to see that
there's no volume change.
That is, if we take the
derivative of delta G of
mixing the partial derivative
with respect to pressure, at
constant temperature, of course,
there's no explicit
pressure dependence.
This is zero.
So again, in the ideal liquid
mixture case, their molecules
aren't interacting.
So there's no reason, when I
open that barrier, that the
amount of volume they occupy
altogether is going to change.
Any questions, so far?
OK.
Then, let's move on to
non-ideal solutions.
By the way, just to return
briefly to this topic of
osmotic pressure, I just want
to emphasize that result
didn't need any kind of energy
of mixing, either, right?
Just from the entropy
term you would burst
the cell or do whatever.
You end up with a
larger pressure.
So in other words, if you have
a situation where, here is A,
pure liquid.
And here is A plus B liquid, so
mu A star is greater than
mu A. We know that in all cases
at the same pressure,
the chemical potential of the
mixture is lower than the
chemical potential of
the pure liquid.
What's going to happen?
Well, A is going to, oh,
sorry, A over here is
going to rush in.
It's going to get through
this, if I've got a
semi-permeable membrane, it's
permeable to A but not to B.
Common situation, of course.
That's certainly the case
for the cell membrane.
Water may flow easily in through
the membrane, but all
of the stuff, all the salt and
everything else that's inside
the cell generally won't.
So of course A then flows
through this, what's called a
semi-permeable membrane.
And you'll wind up with either a
burst membrane, or something
that looks like this.
Where now there is additional
pressure here.
And you'll have some different
mole fraction than you started
with before.
Now let's go over to non-ideal
solutions.
So let's just think
microscopically for a moment
about how this is
going to work.
You know, normally, always,
there are interactions between
the molecules and the liquid.
The liquid is a condensed
phase.
The molecules are in immediate
proximity to each other.
So it's very different from the
gas phase, where it can be
a pretty realistic approximation
to say, well,
the molecules are essentially
non-interacting.
The ideal gas law may turn
out to be a very good
approximation.
In the liquid, really, it's
never the case that you don't
have interactions.
So if we just sketch that.
If we start with a bunch of
molecules in A, they're
interacting.
So there's some interaction
energy.
I'll call it AA, it's the
interaction between two
molecules of A. In most cases
it'll be less than zero.
That is, there'd be
a weak attraction.
Same thing between
molecules of B.
So that's my situation in
the separated liquids.
I've got molecules in
each container.
They're interacting.
There's some energy associated
with that.
So here's the pure separated
liquids.
And now, I'll open up
the barrier and
let the liquids mix.
And now suddenly, of course, A
and B are going to interact
with each other as well
as other molecules
of their own kind.
So now, suddenly, there's going
to be some interaction
energy. uAB.
And very simplistically, we can
envision that for some of
the molecules, essentially,
there would be
exchange of this sort.
So, one neighbor of this
molecule and one neighbor of
this molecule will wind up
exchanged for some pairs of
molecules with the
unlike species.
And essentially, likes
interactions will be replaced
by unlike interactions.
So there's some now change
in energy involved.
There's a delta u.
And as outlined in this simple
picture, it's just 2 uAB minus
uAA plus uBB.
Real liquids are very
complicated.
For liquids with relatively
simple non-directional
interactions, things like
organic liquids that might
interact van der Waal's
interactions.
This might be a reasonable
starting point.
And in general, if we're going
to deal with relatively small
deviations from the ideal liquid
mixture, the ideal
solution, then we can start
with a model like this.
And this difference is what's
going to determine how far the
liquid mixture will deviate from
the ideal solution case.
Of course, we could always just
write a term like this.
It may or may not be easily
expressed in this sort of way.
So let's just think about what
the possibilities are.
Of course, simply,
there are two.
The sign could be positive
or negative.
And what that means is, you
could have situations where
it's positive because basically
there's an energy of
mixing now in these cases.
If that's not zero, unlike the
ideal case, now unlike before,
where we just had entropy
driving the mixture, now
there's an energy of mixing.
Could be positive or negative.
If it's positive, that means
energetically speaking, the
mixture is unfavorable.
In other words, the
intermolecular interactions
between like molecules are
more favorable then the
interactions between the unlike
molecules, in that case.
So, delta u is greater
than zero.
And our delta H of mixing
is going to be close
to delta u of mixing.
That is, we're going to figure
that delta pV is not going to
be something large.
And in that case, we can say
delta G of mixing is 1/4 n.
And that's only because there
are 4 species involved here.
Times delta u.
In other words, I'm
multiplying this
molecular delta u.
This is the change in
energy for this
collection of four molecules.
Or of four molecular pairs.
Plus the other stuff that we've
seen for the ideal case.
That is, the entropy term, of
course, is still there. xA log
xA plus xB log xB.
And because we're treating the
case where this is positive,
that means this is bigger than
in the ideal solution case.
So of course there are lots of
examples of each of these.
In fact, this is the more
common deviation.
So, and lots of examples.
An easy one is acetone.
And carbon disulfide.
So, if we look at that, and
just see what the phase
diagram is going to look like,
it's the following.
So let's start with
the ideal case.
So I'm going to make B the
more volatile component.
That is, B is going to be CS2.
So here's p star CS2, which
I'll call p star B. And
somewhere down here will be p
star for A, that is, p star
for acetone.
And this is going to be the
mole fraction of CS2.
Or xB.
So let's start with
the ideal case.
Not steep enough.
Pretty good.
OK.
And now let's look at
what's going to
happen in the real mixture.
Well, because we've got a
positive deviation, what's
going to happen is the mixing
is unfavorable.
The molecules aren't
that happy any more
about being in solution.
So what that means is,
relative to the ideal
solution, they'd rather go
up into the gas phase.
They don't like being
in the mixture.
Compared to what they would feel
in the ideal solution,
where there are no
interactions.
Because the interactions between
unlike molecules are
unfavorable.
So what's going to
happen, then, is
the pressure is higher.
You have deviations from
the ideal case,
in the total pressure.
And in each of the individual
partial pressures.
That's the total pressure.
pA plus pB.
In the ideal case it's
this straight line.
In the non-ideal case, though,
it's bigger than
the straight line.
Because more stuff wants to
get up into the gas phase.
And it's the same for each
individual component.
So here's pA.
And there's pB.
Any questions?
OK, so it's obvious just from
looking at this that each of
the partial pressures
is bigger than it is
in the ideal case.
And so, so is the
total pressure.
So in other words, if I say
what's the partial pressure of
CS2, well, since it's not the
simple ideal case, actually I
don't know what it
is in general.
It's not easy to calculate a
priori what it's going to do
all the way across the phase
diagram for any mole fraction.
What I do know, though, is it's
bigger than it would be
for the ideal solution case.
In other words, it's bigger than
x CS2 times p star CS2,
the pressure over the
pure liquid CS2.
Same for acetone.
It's bigger than x acetone
p star acetone.
And since both partial pressures
are bigger, the
total pressure has
to be bigger.
And of course, that's something
you can read right
off the diagram as well.
In other words, the total
pressure is bigger than in the
ideal solution case.
Any questions?
OK.
So the negative case,
of course,
is exactly the opposite.
So I'll just go through
it quickly.
So, remember positive deviations
came, let's put
this back up there.
That came from the case where
the unlike intermolecular
interactions are not
as favorable.
There's less attraction, more
repulsion than in this case.
Of course, there are plenty of
cases of the opposite sort.
Where the unlike intermolecular
interactions
are attractive.
More than the interactions
between like molecules.
And in that case, you have
the opposite result.
So you can have negative
deviations.
In other words, delta
u is less than zero.
Lots of examples.
I've got one in the notes,
it's just acetone and
chloroform.
So if we get rid of the carbon
disulfide and put CHCl3 in
there, that's more favorable.
Because there's weak
hydrogen bonding
between the unlike species.
And not between the
like species.
So what happens is, you have
acetone, it's this.
And you have chloroform.
And there's weak hydrogen
bonding between them.
There's an attraction there.
That doesn't exist
between either
case of the like molecules.
So now there's stronger
attraction between them than
there is between molecules
in either of
the pure liquid cases.
So, of course, you know
that the opposite
result is going to happen.
In this case, now you mix them
together, relative to the
ideal solution where there are
no interactions, now they want
to be together.
They're clinging to each other
through these hydrogen bonds.
What's that mean for the
pressure up in the gas phase,
in the solution?
They don't want to go
there any more.
Stuff in the gas phase now wants
to condense down into
the liquid.
Because there they have
favorable interactions.
So that's, of course,
what'll happen.
And so then you just see the
opposite sort of deviation
from what I just illustrated
before.
So then if we look at
p star CHCl3, where
are these lines going?
Well, may have been
more artistic.
But I'm afraid I'm going to
have to go with reality.
p star for acetone.
There's chloroform.
And now our deviation
is going to be in
the opposite direction.
So all the, both of the partial
pressures and the
total pressure are going to go
lower than indicated here.
So p total is now less than,
for the real case, is less
than p total for
the ideal case.
In the situation where you have
attractive interactions
between the unlike molecules.
Any questions?
OK.
Now, in general, this
is complicated.
To describe quantitatively
throughout the
entire phase diagram.
The interactions are
complicated.
Lots of times, molecules
interact with
more than one neighbor.
So in general, we don't have a
simple analytical expression
for what the pressure is going
to do as a function of mole
fraction all the way
from zero to one.
Of course, we have it
in very simple form
for the ideal solution.
Because everything's linear.
So it's very simple.
These are replaced by equalities
and we know
everything.
Now we don't.
But we can at least make some
progress by looking at the
limiting cases.
Where you have just very
dilute solutions.
So in that case, you
can anticipate
what's going to happen.
So let's say we mix A and B.
And one of them is in very
dilute concentration.
For the other one, for B, most
molecules of B are just going
to see themselves.
They hardly know that
you've mixed any
molecules of A in there.
For them, it's pretty much
an ideal solution.
They think they're in
Which is to say there's an
entropy change in mixing.
But hardly any of them
experience interactions with
the unlike molecules.
For the dilute molecules,
there is a change.
You can't use Raoult's
law any more.
But at least we can look of
the slope of the curve and
say, OK, at least in the dilute
solution case for a
little while it's going
to be linear.
We can understand it.
We can tabulate it.
So let's look at
how that works.
Alright.
That limit is something that has
a name, that's called the
ideal dilute solution.
Not to be confused with
the ideal solution.
Where both constituents
follow Raoult's law,
as we've seen before.
So ideal dilute solution.
We're going to just look
at these limits.
So, if we start with the ideal
case, so let's imagine we're
going to look at carbon
disulfide again.
Here's p star CS2, which
is our pB star.
And this is x CS2, or xB.
OK, well, what happens
if we've got
almost pure carbon disulfide.
Well, what's going to happen is
in this limit, like I was
mentioning, up here the CS2
pretty much sees other CS2.
It thinks it's in an
ideal solution.
It's going to look like that.
Now, let's go to the
other limit.
So this is the limit x CS2
equals xB approaches one.
Raoult's law.
Two, the other limit. x
CS2 approaches zero.
We're down here.
So it's definitely not
going to be the same.
Because now, every molecule,
every CS2 molecule, is
completely surrounded
by acetone.
So they all feel the
energy of mixing.
Because there are hardly
any of them there.
So every one of them is, it's
very rare for one to find a
neighbor of its own kind.
And this is a case where there's
a positive deviation
from ideality.
That is, the interactions
are less favorable
between unlike species.
So, it's up here.
Doesn't like that.
It says, get me out here, I'd
much rather be in the gas
phase, compared to the ideal
case, then surrounded by all
these acetone molecules,
right?
So that's what'll happen.
And now it's up to the artist.
But in some way there's
going to be a set
of values in between.
And the ideal dilute solution by
itself isn't going to tell
us about that.
It's telling us about
the two limits.
Now, if we follow this,
and I can see I'm
going to be in trouble.
But I can do a little creative
bending of the line here.
If I follow this slope
up to here,
it'll intercept somewhere.
That has a name.
It's called the Henry's
law constant.
I can write it as
K CS2, or KB.
So the point is, that at
least for some range of
concentrations, the variation
is linear.
And what that means is, if
I know this Henry's law
constant, for CS2 mixed with
acetone specifically, it would
be different.
If it's mixed with something
else, right?
Other kinds of interactions with
different energies will
have a different slope.
But if I know that number,
it's still useful.
Because at least for that pair
of constituents, I know the
dependents for some range
of concentrations.
So this is Henry's
law. p CS --
Oops, CS2 is x CS2
times K CS2.
Not quite as convenient
as Raoult's law.
That number, I don't need
to know what the other
constituent is.
It's just a property of CS2.
It depends on the temperature,
but not the other member of
the mixture.
This one does, but still there's
at least a substantial
number of these things
tabulated.
Especially for important
mixtures.
So it becomes useful for
dilute solutions.
And there's an awful
lot of chemistry.
There's an awful lot of biology
that happens in
relatively dilute solutions.
OK.
I'll leave it at this point.
Next time we'll look at the
total phase diagram, just like
we did last time looking at
both the liquid and gas
coexistence curves, and seeing
what the behavior is as a
function of mole fractions.
And we'll talk about
distillation and so forth in
non-ideal liquids.